je vais récupérer le chat khandan on va
pouvoir voir tranquillement y aller pour
pour une bonne petite session de bleach
et parme a joué pendant une heure une
heure et demie et on va voir ce que ça
va donner
allez c'est parti
trois minutes ouais et ça y est on est
bon on y est c'est bien pour la musique
allait on joue contre halte à almaty
wanlov c'est donc un joueur apparemment
de almaty au kazakhstan et s'est pas
mort tu as ce pas mieux parce que maître
international automatiquement ça peut
pas être mûr tass c'est un peu la bonne
nouvelle
glauque et décale 5f six dessins
convoqué on transpose dans une slave en
jouant dans cet ordre de coûts de 3 ans
quand on va juste faire réussissent on
va juste faire russie ce qu'est kf3 qui
avait 17 tous assez théorique dames
c'est de l'anti mais rend fou des six
cas probables ont compté par food et 3
ici peut aussi jouer b3 hockey g4 qui
étrange les quatre qu'on a déjà vu
plusieurs fois ensemble c'est pas
forcément la meilleure variante insurgés
4 mais c'est juste que je me rappelle
pas super bien de de la théorie est ici
surtout prendre je crois que jusque là
on est bon du coup on va faire dame f6
enfin on veut faire damer fils au
prochain et pardon pour le problème sur
l'écran
ok ça recadre et du ku'damm f6 hockey
foot et de cavalia fuite fou 17 b 5
mégas savoir fois qu'on joue secoue
depuis les gens font grand roque du
qu'on peut faire fou 17 est ici du
couffo 17 pas forcément joie parce que
dame prend bessette
donc il veut empêcher un bon football et
pourquoi pas du coup j'ai envie de quand
même je kg 6
et sur grand roque vais réfléchir du
coup je peux pas news pas du tout faire
food et c'est ici
je peux pas du tout faire fou 17
gnassingbé 3 c'est intéressant appelle
vraiment mon développement avec ce coup
là qui est à 5 me donne pas envie non
plus mon poste vraiment un problème qui
était je vais prendre en d2 du cou
bloqué s'y prendre la tour d'un côté ce
qui est pas mal c'est qu'il pourra plus
doubler sur la colonne g sa règle pas le
problème de ce fou ça n'arrête pas de
problème de mon fou donc à faire petit
rock mais on va mettre le rouge suite à
un peu profité du fait qu'il est plus
fou de 15 mois pour se mettre sur casino
avec le roi est ok malin il fait ce plan
ok je pense que je peux faire à 5
maintenant quand même j'ai loigné leroy
et authier
j'ai du mal à calculer pour le moment
donc je vais faire b5 forcément très
bien joué au hockey je donne un pur
moment je m'active j'ai plus trop de
temps plus trop l'habitude cette cadence
3 0 j'ai surtout joué en bullet et et
les title tuesday dernièrement encore à
faire ces 4 on va aller s'envoyer à fond
sur b2 mettre leur mac le cavalier e set
uk est pas mal placé contre la cage g8
c'est important il faut le savoir
ok on va supprimer le cavale du coup on
en a assez content d'avoir échangé notre
mauvais fond puisque tout est sur blanc
on va mettre la tour en b 8
on va taper le pion b2 paraît difficile
pour lui à défendre qu'il doit il va ce
probablement faire d'am dam des de
hockey dames c'est son affaire fou b4
direct on va venir l'agresser avec ses 3
hockey qui avait laissé 6 on va aller
placer un cavalier b4 qu'à faire un
échec
nakhlé cavagnan b4y la tour c'est ici
sur dame prend vraiment tout est fermé
du coup je vais aller faire qu'elle
prend à deux sur cavaliers ces deux
tours prend b3 on va y aller on va y
aller à l'ancienne je me sens pas en
méga forme mais on va y aller à
l'ancienne en valais le maté à la dure à
la barbara kay ces deux cas et prend à
deux tours prend b3 donc et on va les
prendre ça un de toute façon pas tout
tout ouvrir vallée encaissée saddam
attention même de pas se faire mater à
l'unss du coup du coup du coup les pâtes
ou raciste
je me suis complètement raté j'ai fait
de la merde j'ai fait de la grosse merde
j'ai fait de la très très grosse daube
ok si fedama d'amd 3g tour c'est un math
et du coup du coup du coup du coup du
coup du coup du coup ok on va réussir
encaisser ça maintenant il faut survivre
quand il va ramener le fou en défense si
on peu mince yaka et 17h est il qu'on
rentre dans cette finale il va faire
pour g8 j'imagine ou pas d'ailleurs et
on veut aller faire un échec
ok on va les encaisser son pion va le
faire tomber
on va le faire tomber les gens et on va
dire qu'on mérite la victoire
on va le faire tomber on va dire qu'on
mérite la victoire
ok ça craint il faut qu'on prenne move
faucomprez move de partout
yes yes yes rentre chez toi boom bien
l'arnaqué allez on est reparti on va
faire quatre cavaliers 3 qui reviennent
s'ils viennent à manquer rosso limon on
saura alors qui est là qui dit salut on
est là comment ça va bonsoir à toi ok
vous 17 tours e13 jouer avec ses 3 on
veut remettre le fond f1 on va aller se
planquer h3g 4 ça va aller ça
mam au quai on va faire j'ai quatre
détroit comme ça se lit dans le fou qui
revient flanqué tôt kefu g21 auquel
phare 5 des 4
ça prend va ramener l'eau de cavalli si
on est pas très important de se faire
attaquer de partout sur la colonne h ici
parce qu'on reste on reste solide on a
toutes les pièces là qui protège toutes
les cases 1h 1h 2h 3h 4 tout est bien
défendu
caissie veulent changer le foot
quasiment art c'est pas un souci ok on
va échanger ça ici et on va faire dam
des deux autres comme ça on va échanger
les dames et on va rester avec le bon
fou contre le mauvais fou mais souley
pas si mauvais que ça parce qu'il est
passé devant la chaîne de pioncer un
espèce de mauvais fou de la française
mais qui s'est bien améliorée ressemble
un peu au foot là car au cas de la vente
d'avant ce qu'on va faire bkg pas trop
comment comment continuer ici mon foot
cases blanches pas très utile et
finalement cette colonne h
donc on va faire des quatre pour le
moment et à 3 on va essayer d' un peu
bloqué ça mais je suis pas très très
confiant je n'aime pas trop ce qu'ils
ont des 4 6 1 pour attaquer comme visée
il va doubler sur la colonne donc à
faire qualifier trois ça permettra
toujours de tenir la case h1n1 peut
libérer le fou mais il faut trouver un
plan maintenant il faut manger un peu de
mal
car à leur tour trois tours ces trois
ans à venir d'être pas mal blindés quand
même pour le moment la colonne h on va
essayer d'aller contre et un peu
colonnes c'est voir un peu ce qui se
passe on va mettre le foin f1 non ça me
fait un peu peur là il ya le fou qui
arriveront eux quatre bon ok j'ai
l'intuition qu'il faut aller prendre ça
de toute façon mes tweets mais le cas et
on sait qu as tu vas leur sacrifier
là-dessus double sacrifice de qualité
bouhoun dégagerait tes qualités on s'en
fiche c'est de la merde
il étend ses 5
ok ok ça je m'en fous en fait j'encaisse
cette merde encaissé moi cette merde et
qui avalise les cinq sages allaient
encaisser cette mère dans re4 maintenant
le fou un g2 très bien placé et je vais
avoir deux pions pour la kalach et
l'arrivée d'une pieuvre pieuvre dans ta
gueule je veux plus te voir des gages de
l'alma tier one love
la pieuvre dans ta gueule tu dégages
on veut plus te voir menace qu'un bref
cette menace de partout ok on va prendre
ça on va les ramener le calme en d6
yvette en pls boum boum la pieuvre bout
ok on va faire dame c1 on va me va
menacer tour on va menacer tour c'est
cet échec dans le bon tempo
j'ai envie de vous dire on est bon pour
ta qualité tu dégages
mais pas mal le fond j'ai deux
monstrueux se fout il imite complètement
l'activité des deux tours et il est là
boubé 5
on va continuer à ouvrir les lignes
proche de 3 ok ok
quand même et ça ici en b6 et on va
essayer de faire bessette et tour c8 et
du coup ci prend va faire dame b2 et on
va aller le cas on va faire bessette et
on va faire tourner ses huit échecs et
des huit dames boom boom le pion
bessette simple on revisite cyan
chez patou redonne b2 chez parce que je
suis en train de faire lâche en train de
craquer bon j'ai envie de dire j'en veux
dire ça devrait aller
un banquet pour ces huit échecs sur roy
ici tours à huit échecs il va devoir
prendre prendre on va mater en bessette
en force avec la dame boom dégage voilà
bravo bien je suis ici revient à almaty
one love is a compris que ce n'était pas
le matin ici on bat du coup ok il
revient il revient dans son anti mayrand
ok on va se battre à fond
trop de pls ce qui va rejouer la même
variante on sait rien les gens je peux
pas vous dire ok baronne de moscou du
coup 1-1 et joue ça avec flash
qu'attaquer j'aime pas trop jouer c'est
en 800 fait mais ok il va falloir faire
on n'a pas le choix les gens ok ça c'est
pas très bien réputé ça c'est pas mal
quoi c'est pas mal ce qui se passait pas
très bien réput avant mais que du coup
maintenant c'est jouable cette merde
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas je
n'aime pas jouer cette variante avec les
noirs en glisse insupportable les boules
dégage dégage avec tes pièces nerfs
jiafu prend à chaque [ __ ] complètement
nulle quoi j'étais sûr que j'allais
commencer à faire des conneries dans
cette variante fait chier quoi
[ __ ] je suis complètement
je suis complètement raide un cavalier
katché pas on va essayer de se battre à
mon équipe herman car il sait peut-être
de mettre la tour en fuite après les
défendre moquée dame b6 il va falloir
aller broc et maintenant et puis aller
contre attaque et son roi ok ok tour un
jeu 16 hockey si fait qu'ils avaient
presque 4 g dames prend des quatre est
prise
ok je prends quelques équipes
réussissent dame prend 1,5 en fait et je
vois rien pour lui la dame couvre ses
sept la dame coups de partout le coût
est attaqué le cavalier est attaquée jeu
masqué prend 1,5 ici en bonus qui on va
encaisser ça
on n'est pas super bien là forcément au
caire rock
du coup ce qui a aidé ici sont va
prendre prendre à sacrifier la dame mais
on va avoir des pions on aura des pions
des pions ruiz
ok on va prendre on va reprendre du
cavale et on va
[ __ ]
j'avais une idée puis je les plus bas
j'ai envie de ruiz eefje quelque chose
et je ris discipline tous là du coup
cette fleur qui a aidé trois sapeurs
tourcoing est stocké sur dame frange il
faut prend 1 h 2 mais surtout reprend je
suis un peu dans la merde et je vous
souhaite faire c'était fou prend tout
reprend détroit et tout reprend h5 en
fait pour récupérer son fou et jouer
cette finale
j'ai pas trop ce que ça vaut les gens je
vais mettre ma tour en 17 ans fait je
pars me prends des chèques qu'on va
rester solide et on va essayer d' un peu
poussé tout ça peut-être le fou en d5 la
tour en ces sept on va essayer de va
essayer de pousser sans prendre de
double attaque peut-être on va pousser
le mf5 je m laurent besset peut-être
même pouces f5
je veux pas d'une intuition pour se
coiffe 5 suis pas sûr que ce soit bon
empêche
ok il faut qu'on pousse les pions à fond
on n'a plus trop de temps là ok on va
pousser comme des brutes donc acheter
sur qui ferait ça
du coup ça petit père pénible en fait ce
pion passé j'ai mal géré le truc il
fallait pas laisser faire deux pions
passé qu'elle va faire un pion à essayer
de pousser ses pions comme des brutes
les tours f5
on va mettre le roi sur blanc mais qu'il
s'y passe surtout reprend à y aller à
dame ici échec ok ok ok c'est de la
merde c'est de la merde total
je crois qu'on est complètement perdue
malheureusement peu plus trop défendre
ça va prendre le pion ici et donc ça
s'est perdu autant on peut initier une
onde tada du roi mais bon plus de temps
là malheureusement
j'ai malheureusement ce qu'on aurait
presque pu le
bizarrement presque plus le farcir là du
coup on perd du matériel la part un
miracle droit français 4 ses pattes
mesdames français 4 seimat hockey
dommage dans sympa comme parti il manque
un peu de deux vitesses mais c'est assez
agréable
ok du coup on va faire une trompe offs
qui ont changé ouverture finaux gagne
des points de ce maître international il
joue pas mal hein et puis pas très bien
classé 1 2370 c'est pas qui c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a son nom c'est vrai
mais bon c'est pas gai ni pâques c tpat
iupac cf gainey pack lui c'est que un
pack c'est pas deux pacsées un pack ok
je veux doubler les pions double 1 il
préfère fou des trois cavaliers cinq
cavaliers jeu 2 je comprend pas vraiment
ce qui fait je vois ce qu'il fait avec
ces pièces là je ne comprends pas pâques
j'adore son nous en fait un seul pack
je comprends rien franchement à son
placement de pièces ok je vais prendre
un point de vue pratique on warocqué
rapidement l'air d'être assez pratique
de jouer comme ça que je vais faire à
trois je préparais b4 peut-être jeu
peut-être demain et c'est d'enfermer
saddam en fait à un moment donné un mais
il aura sa dame pourra toujours partir
là bas elle pourra se barrer du coup non
du coup saâdane pourra toujours se
barrent 1,5
manqué de mettre ma tour en c1
je suis pas convaincu par mai dernier
coup j'ai oublié en fait sur b4 qui on
prends tu comprends il est toujours une
casse de repli aucun rajout de quatre
tours en serbe forcément bien passé
chance de jouer deux trois coups un peu
moyen la mecque la tour 7 tours là doit
aller en d1 en fait ouais j'ai bien fait
de la merde au km5 faut en profiter pour
aller pécho pécho h7 aller boum ça on
encaisse
on va être lors le fou ici prêts à venir
en f3 je manquais c est à prendre avec
le cavalier probablement je pense que je
joue très mal hein cette partie et j'ai
l'impression que je vois pas grand chose
je me sente pas être en forme mais bon
donc affaire d'âme eu quatre dames f3
d'amuser et 4
car affaire d'âme f3 ok le carré lieu de
tient la caste des 4 contre le cavalier
donc ça ça va et du coup on va ramener
ce cavalier ici on va faire b4g envie
d'essayer de 8 pouces et ses 5 après
pour essayer d un peu clarifier le jeu
mais tin cavagnan décisif et parfums
changer un peu quelque chose sur sept
ans pense dans cette partie je montre
avec un carillon des trois ça va puer
non c'est vraiment de la merde
complètement raté ce truc là
hyper mal joué on te
regardez prendre ça
dans sa robe rouge et une tour un sens
prise du coup on va pousser comme des
brutes donc à pousser comme des brutes
donc je vais être un cavalier site a dû
menacer 6 maintenant qui c'est ok
et la très problématique
et si très problématique pour ils sont
complètement perdus
qui est prise prise prise
très très mal joué
je vais plus viser le match je pense
j'ai mieux joué en milieu de nuit et
puis après problème c'est qu'il ya un
math en b1
il fallait parer le mat à y joue pas mal
quand même
7 quel point aussi servant marché
probablement qu'un an de l'e3 je sais
pas mais du coup pas super bien joué
j'ai assez mal pour le en fait je vois
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment rien
pour le moment
le mec joue hyper mal aussi mais bon
malheureusement il manque un peu de
temps dommage ce qui est assez nul aussi
tombé de la vraiment pénible
actuellement du coup
les goûts dommage aïe aïe aïe on fait si
mal classé studio bon je suis pas assez
sage abandonné il m'a pas l'air d'être
très très fort il a rendu une pièce et
tout ça donc du coup en plus il joue des
ventes
ah non non non je voulais pas prendre je
vais faire à 6 6 avant qu'est ce que
c'est que ça n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi
mais en plus ils jouent cette variante
dont je me rappelle plus la théorie aïe
aïe aïe aïe c'est page 3
je suis pas p4 mais je sais pas c'est
pas du tout ça qu'est ce que je suis en
train de [ __ ]
méfions h3 je me rappelle d'une certaine
variante il est bien placé mais b4 c'est
très étrange et à ce que je suis en
train de faire un tête damage cinq ici
question
bon ok on va voir donc évidemment mais
c'est juste n'importe quoi ce que je
fais et enfer d'amd 500 passera toujours
damage 5 qui éduque on va récupérer ça
on peut essayer de réfléchir à quelque
chose tu sais pas qui c'est peut-être
quelque chose ici
sa mère assez merdique
donc je tente et c5
on en est où avec les pions 2 4 6 7 on
l'a 7 pions quand même il y en a combien
il enlace est aussi des gens de partout
du coup on essaie de prendre en g2
mais du coup je suis obligée de rester
là avec le fou à cause de cette tour
l'instruction est super bizarre qui
comprend rien
et encore qu'il sait 6
on qu'elle jugeait pas tant que c'est
pas mal de développer ça
ok
bon avec le fond g7
un faire grève six en fait je vais
essayer d'en faire une cavale
j'essaie d'en faire une cavale
en fait je veux faire rager set
peut-être juste 3 prend la fuite en fait
trucs comme ça
tours j'ai un jeu contre la france et
cinq messages menace ça
ok
surtout reprend à schwyz veut faire tour
g8
je veux faire cavalier 7 en fait la
nouvelle fois je suis un peu mal autant
parce que novak a eu 7 c'est que je
couvre plus avec le fou mais ce que
j'aime bien c'est qu'en fait la gymnaste
ou reprend cavaliers j'empêche tour g8
du coup parti ultra tactique je suis
trop vieux pour ça les gens jeu masqué
j'en fais piéger 6 aussi et surtout
reprendre dessin ce que je veux faire
c'était fou pranger a en fait allé
prendre la barre en géant ok si je fais
une sieste faire cavalier prends je pas
trop compris en face et tout reprend du
coup je viens juste d'encaisser une
calloc'h eia le cavalier qui tombe
comment j'ai les deux fous les deux bons
vivants
bon ok juste encaisser ça maintenant et
ça c'est juste gagne on va faire un
échec en faire deux échecs d'avoir trois
échecs peut pas faire droit à trois pas
ce qui a poussé 5 matteo qui ont
encaissé ça ça c'est complètement
gagnant
justement qu'est sélection une gaffe
monumentale de déconcentration
ça devrait être bon
comme à pousser les pions en fait tout
bêtement
ok paraît bien joué par le refus de sa
part mais en fait ça ne suffit pas parce
que le truc c'est que notre fou vient
sur la diagonale et là ça fait un peu
trop de pions pour notre adversaire ok
comme anne boquet il a un pas un gros
lots mais c'est parti assez sympa et on
va le reprendre dans la vallée le
reprendre dans la sicilienne ça un peu
embêté ans je connais pas bien et
peut-être c'est de faire un genre de de
gambie mora mais je connais pas non plus
que j'ai choix entre plusieurs choses ne
connaissent que je ne connais pas
je connais pas je connais pas du tout en
fait
je n'ai pas ça me paraît logique neige
une certaine logique du forçage ou six
pour essayer de tournicoter sur le pion
des six faits par un je n'ai pas le
temps ni moi j'ai regardé pour l'avoir
fois de ma vie a pas si longtemps que ça
avec un élève mais bon j'ai pas regardé
ça pour moi donc du coup je me rappelle
pas bien mais je me rappelle que le pion
des six quelque part peut être un peu
affaibli y ait là peut-être que premier
gant dimora halal gambeat aux morts lls
mis ses membres à en encaisser ça vient
il donc que c'est encore une fois est de
faire dan b5 dame prend en fait
qui en fait un échec
a créé une petite menace peut-être faire
un deuxième échec en 17 ans j'ai eu
envie de montrer ma tour sur la septième
jeu vers damas trois quand même parce
que je veux faire cinq là maintenant
boum 5 tu touche pas à mon fou amincie
pas f 4g pas f400 guelph et
éventuellement faire cavale de quatre
je laisse cette merde emprise et juan
caisse à et du coup son cavalier voir
beaucoup de mal à se défendre d'un look
et après je vais aller doubler sur la
7ème ça est une horreur du même j'ai
même du sma tour étant prises quel idiot
fini je suis complètement oublié que
cette tour étant prises au nom donc et
du ku'damm des six j'ai envie de dire
bien obligé de défendre le pion le pion
que c'est pas fini
comment est-ce que j'ai pas vu que cette
emprise comme ça ok bon j'ai 3
dans cette cavale f6 j'ai hésité mais
car ici j'aime bien parce que je menace
de prendre 7 sur échec du coq et se
barre je prends ok il se défend pour le
moment que j'ai encaissé son pion
je vois pas grand chose là j'aurais dû
faire ça autrement
j'avais une variante avec un père pète
j'aurais peut-être dû prendre là nul ok
on va faire h trois ans pour commencer
ce que je sens qu'il ya des maths de
partout j'aime pas trop impose comme à
couvrir
je suis contre attaquer sur le plan f 7
ok ça va ça ça doit se défendre
normalement de manière active toujours
jouer activement finale
toujours joué de manière active en
finale
donc un même plateau ici et s'arrêtent
nul ça
donc à aider c'est peut-être marché qui
avait huit possibles non ça c'est idiot
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai joués ce coup
idiot
malheureusement ce pas trop grave
car faire des échecs maintenant ok
seamless encaisser ça qui sait peut-être
même je l'aï gagnée en fait
que ça saigne normalement ça laurence
nuls
ok juste me faire tomber en fait quel
idiot
quel idiot ok ces cas-là tonton dans ces
cas-là tonton c'est toi qui la perd j'ai
envie de te dire justice et c'est y pas
de gagner ce que t'es pas capable de
gagner mais qu un calumet clé point
d'interrogation que nos mains québec
font pas si fantastique et c'est y pas
de gagner ce que tu peux pas gagner mais
qui n'essaye pas de jouer dur si t'es
pas un dur j'ai envie de te dire voilà
le matin tu la gagnes cela ici mais si
ça endroits différents quoi
bon de toute façon il aurait pu répéter
les coups voilà peut-être tour à shermag
possible bon allez on va essayer de
prendre un autre mec donc ya pas eu
d'offre digne de mon côté ça c'est sûr
bon ok on va essayer de ne consommer que
plus fort
ok ces mecs là est assez fort j'ai perdu
pas mal de fois contre lui il est plus
fort que moi ok on va essayer de jouer
ça
un carnage avec g3 foulée 2
ok
je vais pas juger du foot et accouche en
quoi je fais je fais ça en fait je suis
vraiment pas prêt j'échange fou de cas
de l'enfance
j'ai envie de sacrifier mais bon ça me
titille l'esprit de sacrifice du matos
l'américaine
ok j'ai trop envie
j'ai un ensemble de plus rien à voir par
contre
donc et franck et c'est le troisième
option et puis jouer c'est avec trois
pions de plus les trois points quand
même trois pions donc à ça j'avais vu
roi 2 qui est d'amener 5 d'un prend des
5 et georges de jouer cette finale
en quelques années ici
f6 leur cavale ie6 kf4 un truc c'est que
j'ai envie de vivre ce cavalier du coup
il permet à le placer en fait parce
qu'il est complètement limité par les
pions farouk et j'aime bien cette pause
en fait je faire cailler jesse
spécifique à la fuite du cépage est un
peu son pouvoir faire h5 elle peut faire
dame e cat éventuellement peut-être vers
4 paraît pas mal
très bon billet composition
ok je faire j'ai quatre je suis pas très
bien autant donc et d'un missile me fait
pas peur je fais juste 3 3 ok tout mon
idée c'est de faire g5 maintenant
ok faire g6 et je veux juste mettre mon
rang en f3 en fait
du coup tourcoing f4 d'emprunt f4 dame
bouger ok je peux pas mettre mon rang on
savait qu'ils allaient faire ça je
passais leurs pions prend
ok c'est hyper bizarre genre dame de roi
ou trois projets 3d genre il a plu des
chèques
c'est compliqué je suis trop vieux pour
ça franchement les gens vous me tirer
vers le bas
jusque là j'ai vu m du coût d'un rêve
cette année g8 maths et auquel mecs se
fait mater sicile tonton g7 et g8 à la
commande ok pas mal hein le sacrifice de
pièces et la structure de pions et le
roi qui monte content de cette partie
d'air si jamais ça il peut faire elle
peut jouer avec eux quatre fichiers
[ __ ] [ __ ] fléchier j'aime pas joué
contre cette variante
il faut que je m'accroche contre ce mec
là plus fort que moi [ __ ]
donc madame b 6 qu'est ce que c'est que
ce bordel encore
et je suis à l'encaisser ce pion mais je
veux surtout pas à jouer ce genre de
position contre ce type ok grand roque
en a qu'une vie
ok d'une bonne intention pour prise et
j'ai cinq genres jeux hyper pratique
genre fou prend un tour g8 je t'emmerde
j'ai mes pièces sur la deuxième je sais
pas je me bats
les fous g7
la petite madame seront fermés [ __ ]
ça craint
je me suis complètement
mystifié
j'ai fait de la merde mais j'ai dix ans
mais qui a un mauvais match up ont
toujours beaucoup de mal contre lui donc
la main assis ce qu'elle veut faire
cavaler pays si ça les contre-attaqués
c4 quintuple content d'être en vie tu
faire genre à 6 tours 8
ok j'en prends
donc je vais cacher ça je comprends pas
trop ce coût ce qui est un succès pas vu
tout simple je suis très content de ce
qu'il vient de faire en fait ce que j'ai
toujours la pression sur ces quatre
absents sur re5 moment j'ai l'impression
d'être bien j'espère donc et c'est juste
envie d'encaisser jeux med c'est ici
mondou pas à première vue ça va mais
après ok faire d'amis si j'arrive pas
calculé jean
j'ai une grosse envie de faire ton aussi
s'y fait d'amis sied d'un français caté
joué la finale en fait ce que je pense
du meilleur que lui en finale et même
cette finale est inférieur je suis assez
confiant
on va jouer ça assez vite en fait ça on
a récupéré notre notre retard à la
pendule et une position bien dynamiques
comme je les aime avec les cavales de
partout les menaces de partout il ya
tout qui en prise aux quais du coup je
faire kaïs c5
j'avais pas vu entre guillemets
aïe
ça c'est pas prévu
donc elle a mieux joué que moi mais pas
rentrer dans la finale ça c'est hyper
mal joué je remets ton france et 7 mais
bon c'est un peu horrible un ce que
j'aime faire
j'ai plus de temps
non je plus vite qu'elle est finalement
ma petite finale que je m'en fiche du
fou plus ou moins ce que je voulais
obtenir sa boo boo dégage
c'est que je déplore que l'on finale a
fini par craquer c'est pas la première
fois qu ils me se montre fébrile en fin
de partie
comment c'est pas la première fois
qu'ils se montrent fébriles en fin de
partie
c'est un peu son point faible
rien qu'à finir par craquer mais en fait
il me laissait pousser mes pions et il
s'est juste assez mal à retrouver
donc on va les prendre et encaisser ça
non j'ai pas trop où est ce que je
prends son pion juge perriquet fait
théâtres en fête
ok du coup maintenant il faut faire
jouer comme ça pour aller récupérer le
pion mais ça a le mérite de ne pas avoir
son fonds arrivant flanqué tôt ce qui
aurait pu être embêtant avec le pion des
cinq ans fait donc on va tout est changé
en patience soit idéale ce que j'ai
obtenu ici
raji vous parlez de retour à 2005 ça va
être difficile quand même les gens parce
que c'est vraiment pas la personne que
j'ai l'habitude de mrdja dame s'est
heureusement qu'il n'a pas vu avait
dames c'est cette double attaque
ok dit qu'on va jouer cette finale qui
est juste moins bien qui va permettre
peut-être joué f4 wave 2 est étonnant
tfo et 2
étonnant qu'il ait changé ça comme ça
qu'un fer f3 on va aller bien des ça
entreprises prises
kerouay du coup je défends avec le roi
que ça c'est pas grave qui est tombé un
tour bekkat on va activer on va mettre
la tour en d4 qui va permettre à
remettre leur ont eu deux en d2 par non
ok on pour le moment je veux ignorer sa
d'affaires g3 je vais prendre ou là si
je prends des 8 kg 2 tu as regardé les
gens tout reprend g2 fini et du coup les
la tourache suite auquel il avait tout
raflé qui était très bien joué on est
très contents qu'ils le fassent pas du
coup là je vais faire prise prises et f4
donc il peut faire j'ai quatre est soi
disant ok ou ce qu'il est en train de
faire et j'ai rien du tout un mais c'est
juste qu'à plusieurs reprises il aurait
vraiment pu presser dans cette finale
n'a pas vraiment fait bon ok c'est un
poil mieux encore avec mon pions c4 mais
normalement ça c'est rien déjà
je peux pas échanger les foins
non non cela risque de stagner si j'ai
changé je perds la kg m ça comme ça
ça c'est complètement nul 1
il y en a un peu raté l'ouverture ce que
je proposais nuit l'a refusée mais ça je
peux pas le perdre
je veux pas jouer cette finale de
nouveau
ok peut jouer autant qu'ils veulent
c'est normalement
ce qu'ils aiment pas trop dur à tenir
fermé en ce moment je suis en train de
jouer trop lentement le voilà donc et du
coup on va plutôt jouer une carreaux
cannes en fait j'aime pas joué cette
variante
avec la superbe voix répertoire de mon
point de vue pour me enfin il a ainsi
fermé respiratoires et un super bon
répertoire pour me pour me gêner par
écrit tout faire avec damage 5 es fou là
bas donc il aura joué accueilli ces 5
je vais [ __ ] madame là bas marans
cavaillon ses cinq jeux pas trop ce que
ça vaut
je pars tout en 8
je pas convaincu
je sais pas pourquoi je joue ça
honnêtement elles traduisent des
catcheuses effacé du craquage peut-être
tu as les cavaliers à 5.6 et surtout mal
ses positions [ __ ] c'est incroyable
est aussi nul
c'est hyper stressant d'être aussi nul
si mal que moi c'est vraiment un
problème franchement
inquiètes ou rue89 un an il faut 7 la
dame qui se font faire mais aussi dans
certaines variantes g4 et madame est
presque en fait j'ai fait n'importe quoi
je me déteste
j'ai également à quatre ça je faire
[ __ ] en p2 en fait
ok vraiment mais même un coup comme j'ai
cap m en pls de niveau 50 pendant je
tiens on sait pas comment
mais si je sais pas de syfy cif et gecas
ge va les sacrifiés de façon enfin bon
ok matches manqués c'est ça du coup là
peut-être sait plus si clair donc j'ai
pris h3c peut-être plus si clair ça
j'avais vu
mais un problème ici ces cavaliers g5 en
fait
basket pro f7 mater bresse la dame est
très très mauvaise partie une tête très
jolie matt d'ailleurs très mal joué
c'est vraiment du mal contre ce mec
bon moment mise à part aller final ça
n'a pas été glorieux croire hockey que
je relise vendre que je compte le joueur
précédent
du coup j'avais théorique en fait
ah on peut pas prendre un rêve sept ans
du coup on a appris quelque chose
prêts
je vais sans théorisé difficile
je jouais sans théorie s'est compliquée
qu'elle lui apparemment il connaît
c'est un gros problème
quand ce juste réfuté dans la théorie
qu'un parent part avec un handicap clair
mais il faut faire cinq caisses
peut-être pas dramatique dramatique
parce que on a encore des tours d un on
a encore des trucs
ok mais ça a très bien joué
qu'il faut tenter de
century fait que des bons coups là
domine sérieusement
il est chargé ce qui connaît pas mal
hein
c'est pour ça que vous si bien la
méthode horizons en fait ce que je parte
tout en ayant un handicap de toute façon
du coup du coup on va essayer de
remonter
marc et on va tenter ça je sais pas
sa part d'être folichon folichon cette
histoire
je me sens d'être perdant en fait ops ou
death oups la tour moi j'étais tellement
derrière que je reviens à peine 1 g 30
secondes
habermas la jpa hesbaye tout le temps là
à dire que je vais tomber de toute façon
misérablement
quel dommage
on aurait pu faire une espèce remonte à
la de la partie j'ai pas vu ici peu de
temps
et je repousse escales valent même
simple dangereux at il vraiment plus de
temps ils voulaient me piéger me mens
jeu rapide à la souris
j'ai cette voie ça va prendre ce que je
fais c'est bien truc c'est que moindre
prix ouvre à t1
il va avec 100 voix hop hop la tour en a
huit up la tour en a huit
et si la torre allez hop
ok
c'est pas mates
ok ça ça pousse jusqu'au bout comment
pas mal pas mal c'est insultant sur la
pendule nouvelle fois la finale qu'ils
prennent c'est un peu son répertoire qui
me gêne bien
ce répertoire me gêne pas mal et on va
jouer comme maxime aujourd'hui non si je
venais de faire casser
heureusement qu'il n'a pas pris
j'ai pas mes gars spécialiste de cette
ligne je ne joue jamais ça puis quand il
s'est joint à 6
on tuerait m
puis en baisse est vraiment un problème
mais qui on va faire rage suite en
prenant pour commencer face c'était bien
les charges et les pions à mais c'est
pas juste un projet ouvert ma tour je
vais remettre le fond on réussisse
que je vais changer un peu
c'est pas la dépression qui sont le
répertoire une nouvelle fois je les
comprends pas super bien les anglaises
dans mon coeur on veut prendre du plomb
eux pour faire colonnes semi ouverte et
je l'utilisé matourin
pour ça que deux bases on avait j'aurais
peut-être pu gagner b5 au passage à la
pompe à eau des cds 5 ans maintenant
au carré faire flamber 4
comment ça va
rien jusqu'à 8 au mans ça me permet de
couvrir la première rangée on va faire
ses cinq maintenant protéger le fou dame
ces six baies 5 pouces et 3 up
oups oups j'ai essayé de me pousser
auprès move il a compris qu'ils
perdraient allez on change coup droit
revers car d4 hockey à jouer ça
la première fois que je domine ce mec
ski voir peur de mon sacrifice non on va
écouter un on a gagné une fois comme ça
pourquoi pas de caisse a le mérite de le
mettre sur le plu a rocket je pensais
qu'il allait faire ça encaisser le pion
ça va faire un échec en faire un échec
ankara m le kenyan de 4
donc est moins évident que tout à
l'heure enfin peut-être que là ça va pas
ok jimmy leroy là pour aller me cacher
en h2 éventuellement c'est quand même
une des idées les plus décente que je
puisse avoir
quel final pur de toute façon
il peut faire bouger 6 à tout moment ok
je vais rester prend 1,7
donc il va forcer la finale comme ça ok
je pense que je veux garder le cavalier
sur l'échiquier quand même
tiens je vais situé comme ça
maintenant il va avoir f6
hyper pays comme coup
les cavaliers va revenir sur une bonne
casse est une horreur
ça va être une horreur
je veux pas laisser revenir vers f6
surgelés 4e cat scara du coup si les
pions prend faut que je tente quelque
chose auquel je joue e 4 quitte à jouer
f5 et g4 mais je peux pas laisser ce
cavalier s'installer trop facilement les
cavaliers f6 si c'était très pénible
vraiment de la merde ok je tente
quelques magouilles jeu roigé sèche
peut-être prendre en lice ici à voir le
pion qui pousse ok c'est pas si simple
genre un de tenter des pièges les gens
genre 84 tours prend des trois
éventuellement il prend ici ça j'avais
oublié qui peut juste prendre h7 avec le
cavale
quel j'ai encore deux trois idées de
quel genre kg cinq tours gk3 6-3 f2 avec
des maths on va faire un échec ici pas
super malin d'ailleurs cet échec
ludo hyper idiot
ok il faut prendre j'ai quatre échecs
dont je chante encore quelques petits
pièges
il a plus trop de temps la pendule rmc
qui aura tout rejet 6 au kef au f5
cette surprise prise que permet de faire
le geste chaque est peut-être un espèce
de perpète
j'avais peut-être quelque chose de
beaucoup mieux y siens ah non
on va essayer de le faire tomber
non non c'est fait mater tu as un
problème dans l'ouverture d'ici en plus
de ça j'aurais dû rejouer une anglaise
en fait j'ai été idiot j'étais ravi que
j'aurais dû refaire une anglaise dommage
la dernière en fait j'étais pas s'ils
ont au final qu'on va échanger les dames
je sais pas j'aime pas du tout cette
finale mais ok mais c'est très rapide
aux cavaliers g4 et rapido s'échanger du
matos je vais prendre ça
qui on peut prendre prendre
ok je vais prendre fait retour des 8 /
cavaliers prend à yanbu ses 8 ans prise
à la fin
comment être aussi stupide mais comment
tu peux être aussi des billes
[ __ ] c'est la fatigue
hallucinant
ok tout étant prises maintenant quelle
horreur
quel dramaturgie
clay dramaturgie qui récupère capable de
calculer 3 kw à l'avance moi ok fois ci
j'ai de la chance qui laisse ça
j'imagine être quand même très mal mais
bon
je vais prendre ça ici alors les pions
on en est où il en a 2 4 si j'en ai 4
mai jean menace deux trois tours en
baisse est très bien placé et je vais
peut-être devoir sauver ça
kelkoo sur m6 non même si c'est pas un
bon coup que je vais prendre une fois
ici que du coup il a quoi il a 53 réez
ok tu vas récupérer ça je vais récupérer
sa quête du coup j'ai repris tous les
pions
est-ce qu'on peut jouer ça pour gagner
décemment aubin
qui est vraiment j'en ai envie mais bon
quel jeu c'est vers tours projet 5 et 6
de finir avec un pion de plus mais c'est
nul mais ok mon côté irrespectueux du
niveau des autres en finale car l'action
récupère un pion
et jusqu en poussant son pion il vient
de se rapprocher je crois qu'il est en
train de m'aider en fait ce qui est en
train de il a montré que témoin
fortement finale du coup forcément ça me
donne envie d'essayer de de la gagner 1
c'est logique que je fais retour des 5
et puis à l'encaisser le pion en retrait
avec un film plus bon je sais que je
maîtrise mieux cette phase de jeu fui du
coup c'est logique d'essayer de gagner
on part comme avec deux pions - ok on
poussait
du coup il fait tout reprend pions
prends je réussis a même retrouvé
confirme plus et ci fais pas ça je
réussis encaissé b4 bon je vais être
très confiant de plus les gens
quel sens va l'éloigner et on va pousser
comme des brutes et du coup je vais
couvrir et on va couper le roi up et on
coupe on coupe on coud à la les gens qui
on donne rien
tu pendant quelques instants
comment pensent-ils
ok
ça c'est matt bon grosse technique en
finale hyper facile a finalement n'est
ce pas ça vous impressionne les gens ou
pas est-ce que les gens sont
impressionnés
parce que les gens sont impressionnés de
la technique en finale ou est-ce que les
gens ne sont pas impressionné par la
technique en finale telle est la
question
mince faut pas que je retourne dans
cette sicilienne est ce que les gens on
est impressionné par la technique en
finale ou pas that is the question
on fait ça à l'aveuglé auquel j'ai trois
foulées de gens sont impressionnés gens
s'en prennent ça va toujours
impressionné par la grosse technique
tant mieux tant que j'avais région ne
soit pas impressionné par la technique
bon ok je jamais cette position encore
you ben non c'est pas mal c'est raide
ripoux 98 torture us exactement je tue
mes cavaliers comme ça
ok
je gueule en c4 primaire pas mal placé
je fais de la merde
c'est pas du tout mon répertoire en fait
tout ça je ne sais pas je m'en rappelle
plus de mailing contre le dragon
accélérée du coup ça me met en pls cette
ouverture
l'âge des fonds en finale c'est justin
dans les vrais échecs dans les vrais
échecs en appui tactique en sa grosse
technique placement pièce on va échanger
ça
jennifer c3 je sais pas je comprends je
comprendrais ce qui se passe en fait je
suis choqué et b3g tombé à 1 a vivement
mais bon je vais peut-être vous prend
ses trois as fait de la merde en fait
probablement même
ouais je fais n'importe quoi
bon je farfouille b2 écouter un jeu la
qualité puis on va essayer de faire
quelque chose vous marquerez que quand
je fais n'importe quoi sous emprise
donne des qualités pour à des positions
jouable c'est un truc que j'aime bien
faire en fait donc est un des 2 par
exemple
tu vas mettre le cavalier ici qu'est cif
et puis on prend l'idée est faire dame
g5 france à
que je prends en une fois
ok
qu'il faut qu'on tente en dessous de
façon
juste rien
n'importe quoi en fait vraiment vraiment
vraiment de la merde
vraiment vraiment vraiment la merde je
veux juste en deçà mais si cher que ça
marche pas mal et ça marche pas du tout
en fait
qu'est ce qui fait je comprends rien à
ce qui fait des fois là pourquoi est ce
qu'il a donné une dame mais dieu seul le
sait en fait le mec est complètement
taré roguy meye 14 secondes il ya
probablement de faire tomber tout ça
mais ok mais pourquoi il a fait ça je
crois qu'il ya que lui qui peut qui peut
nous le dire je prends pas du tout à
quoi ça servait le mec qui est juste
hallucinant il joue assez bien et
parfois ils peuvent juste donner une
dame comme ça sans raison
ok malheureusement on va être un peu
court mais bon ok complètement débile
dommage l'accord final il est vraiment
assez nul quand même question puisqu'il
a compris qu'il était nul en finale du
coup il veut plus joué de finale et a
compris que la cour est que les finales
c'était pas pour lui
une façon sûre et content du résultat
contre ce joueur ce que c'était loin
d'être gagné d'avancé
je peux prendre un deuxième pion
je veux juste que j'ai envie d'éviter
tour b1 est ok un pion c'est quand même
un pion du coup j'ai deux pions passer
maintenant
d'ailleurs pendant qu'on y est le redif
les rediff de ces stream seront en
direct seront différées maintenant sur
la chaîne youtube officielle de check
point com
vous pouvez revoir tout ça en replay je
suis poussé mon pions
je vais essayer d'aller mater du coup
c'est j'imagine
je vais pousser mon pions encore un peu
comment je vois pas de bon je vois pas
de maths mais je sens qu'il veut essayer
de me créer un réseau de match moi j'ai
voulu ramener mon fond b3 en fait sur sa
grille mis deux ans à 4 pour me protéger
je me barre avec madame que du coup si
j'élimine un de ses cavaliers quand même
pas mal que je prends de ça ici
qui est possible qu'ils me maths mais
bon
je pense avoir de la marge encore
urbatro quand il peut mater pour le
moment
ok peut mater s'ils ramènent sa tour du
coup je sacrifie madame et je pousse le
pion quoi vous du coup c'est quoi le
matos encore apprendre ça
key si je fais à 2 il prend et je pousse
je fais une autre dame et du coup je me
retrouve avec du matos substantielles en
plus du coup je dame sur échec et je
fais tout rêve cette voie mais attendez
tous rêvent cette île fait non mais ça
va en fait ça il prend là je reprends
ah mince du coup je prends il prend et
je me barre avec mon roi est de nouveau
j'ai plus de temps mais à un moment je
peux pas prendre en d4
ok c'est très chiant
soit je me suis fait avoir
ok 34 c'est bien aidé à me prendre et 4
qui a une nouvelle fois ça joue avec le
temps j'ai essayé de me faire tomber
apprendre à prendre
ok
mission est parfaite
ok on va récupérer ça
c'est comme des brutes
à
non non je me suis ratée avec la lame
non quelle horreur je vais me faire
tomber
[Musique]
non non non non il m'a fait tomber qu'à
l'idiot quel idiot khalid et au cas
l'idée au moral et dernière partie non
allez on y va
allez hop on arrête là dessus tant pis
il est 9h30 on va arrêter là dessus
hyper décevant je jouais beaucoup trop
lentement je fais n'importe quoi
le manque de motivation à la fin quoi
complètement gagnant cette finale
j'aurais juste fait-on g3 je sais pas
pas assez de temps mais je jouais trop
lentement c'est un peu lent aujourd'hui
mise à part sa bomba aux québécois
nouvelle fois pas mal dominés ce mec-là
mef vient on finit que cinq et demi
quatre et demi vu la domination dommage
moi je vous souhaite à tous une bonne
soirée je faire vous êtes bien amusé en
regardant et que ça vous appuyez n'était
pas laisser des commentaires et des
messages dans le tchat
à bientôt ciao